这一袋子我都没有见过
这一袋子应该都是这一批到的
直筒袖啊
直筒袖那叫长袖
和另一件薄荷绿娃娃一起拍的
我只收到薄荷娃娃裙了
是不是没收到那一个
没事没事
如果他真的找不到下次
我找到一件好的也给你便宜点啊
我给你找到的裙子还有
就是说得找
反正现在的话
就是说也穿不了长袖嘛
你稍微等一等
肯定能帮你再找一件
来
胸尾的话是118120
长度的话61
长度61
来这款谁要谁来扣2929
扣个2
来
锯纸只有9%啊
剩下都是棉的
来谁要谁来扣29扣个2
圆领圆领
这个T啊
咱们要买
马上我跟你说春秋天
它打底也可以
单穿也可以
白色的T本来就少
咱们看到了有喜欢的啊
面来的
面料又好的
咱们可以入啊
来2929
谁要谁来扣个2
29扣个2
来这个高领的这个打底衫
高领的这个衣服可以外穿
可以打底的话有点大了吧
后面底边开叉
我看看还有没有标
还有没有标
这个面料也软
棉95聚质5%对吧
我说这个面料也软了
L码
没有品牌标了
这个可以外穿的
来这一款
前面短一点后面长一点
两边开小叉
哦不对不对
不是两边后面
后面开小叉的来
棉95聚质5%啊
棉95聚质5%
胸围胸围
110 116
长度前面62后面71
来这一款谁要2929扣个8
2929谁要谁来扣个8
谁要谁来扣个8
你玩的姐姐衣服29扣8
来这个是160
160 160的甲两件
甲两件这个160 160
它写的面料是聚质的
面料聚质的160的甲两件
前面有交印字母
后背是光满
后背光满的
来这一款我来量一下这个谁要
胸围胸围106
106 112
长度71
来这款谁要29 29扣1
29 29
谁要谁来扣个1
啊19吧
160给你们19
给你们便宜点
给你们便宜点姐妹们
160的给你们前面
其实大人都能穿了
对不对挺大的
来这一款米色的
F码G码
没有品牌标了
全棉
前面有风机扣
有拉链
腰上有出绳
小直筒
小直筒啊
两边有斜拉口袋
屁股后面有口袋
有口袋的啊
这个是这个牌子
这个牌子的
这个牌
棉一百
棉一百啊
来这一款
咱们来量一下
你们听一下
来来来
腰尾的话是
七十四
七十六
臀尾的话是
一零六
一零八
来
当长三十七
裤长九十五
来这种裤子
谁要谁来扣
三十九
扣五
棉一百啊
棉一百
我感觉这个像男裤
对吧
感觉像男生穿的
这个啊
谁要谁来扣
三十九
扣五
棉一百
棉一百的姐妹们
冲啊
全棉
来这个家居裙
浅蓝色
浅蓝色的这个花的家居裙
面料是人棉一百腰上有抽绳
领口有扣有扣呀的
下摆是个蛋糕式的啊
下摆是个蛋糕式的这一款家居裙
家居裙
来面料打打舒服啊
你想想人年一百的多舒服呀
胸围九十六
腰围的话是七十八九十六
七十八九十六
来裙长裙长
是一二二
裙长一二二
来这一款谁要谁来扣十九十九
扣一扣一
来喜欢的姐姐就扣十九扣一
人棉一百的这个家居裙
十九十九扣一扣一
喜欢的姐姐就扣
好的
嘉宾给你了
超级划算
来亲爱的
三八七
三八七现在都放福利了
原来都不是这个价
来387
好截图谢谢
面料舒服的很
谢谢小妹
看圈
OK
买给儿子
谢谢我亲爱的先皇
我直接拍给他就行了
谢谢
来这个裙子来给保姆看一下
领口上
它上面身是有扣有扣牙的单层
底下是摆折的
腰上有松紧腰
还有一个腰带
袖口也是有扣有扣牙的
来这个裙咱们来量一下
面料是锯纸
就是那种滑滑的
亮亮的滑滑的这种面料
亮亮的滑滑的
来胸围
胸围100
腰围的话是6480
裙长的话是121
裙长121
来这个裙子谁要谁来扣29
29扣个2
原价59的姐妹们
原价59的29 29
谁要谁来扣个2
来面料丝滑的很
好的
太给力了
来
来389
太给力了
321好谢谢
谢谢谢谢
太给力了
来这个裤子是超好看的
但是他的腰太小了
他写的都是小码
加s xl
xl
他的腰围看一下腰围这个派
版型都很好的
两边有鞋拉口袋中高腰的直筒裤
如果你觉得这个裤脚大了
咱这有裤子
有裤也可以扣上去一点的
来看一下
他的腰围这里是有有弹力的
但弹力不是特别大
我来量一量你们听一下
谁能穿的谁就扣
这个裤子还是个整款
又太小了
腰围平铺60
可以拉到64
团围110
可以拉到110
来当场36
当场36
裤长92
来这种裤子谁要谁来扣
来3939扣个3
谁要谁来扣个3
灰色的灰色的这个直筒裤
谁要谁来扣39扣个3
来
这个
小短裙
来这一款来给帮我们看一下
来这一款腰式松紧腰
他这个是含年70多的
这还是尼龙河巨脂
腰式半腰松紧的这个短裙
短裙腰后面带松紧腰的腰后面带松紧腰的来
这个小短裙
咱们来量一下腰围60可以拉到76
团围110可以拉成了122群长43
来这一款谁要9块9块。
兑一9块9块
谁要谁来扣个一
红衣啃一下
来这个马甲裙
暇你要来强力推荐一下马甲裙
这个带花边的啊
肩膀上袖子
这里带花边的来
这个马甲裙前威后威
但是后面有个派 ninety
后面有个派 ada后面底边开离
后面底边开走这个米色米色纳uum跑车
来这一款裙子怎么加裙
咱来量一下
胸围
104 106
腰围和胸围是一样的啊
来裙长
裙长
来这个裙子原价49的
现在给大家也是29
29扣个6
单层看看
质量做工嘎嘎好
谁要谁来扣29扣6
咱们夏天直接这样单穿
天凉一点的话
咱们可以就是叠穿
来谁要谁来扣29
29啊
马甲裙
非常好看的这个米色马甲裙
29 29
扣个6扣个6
我看看还有啥好看的裙
给你们过一过啊
这后面的裙子又好久没过了
来这个花的
有红花
有大红色的这个是灰色
这个是灰色啊
来这个前面它是有一排这个扣子的
看到了吗
有一排这个小扣子
扣子全部都是用这种面料包的扣
来这一款咱们来量一下
它的袖口是松紧的啊
咱们虽然看是长袖
但是它可以拉成短袖
可以拉成短袖
看弹力很大
这个面料穿在身上舒服的很
舒服的很啊
来这一款威灵威灵
来腰式松紧腰长裙
咱们来量一下你们听一下
我妈呀又出来了又得叫
又得要验证
胸围100 106
腰围70可以拉到86
裙长125
来这个裙子原来69的
也给你们29
扣个1啊
29 29谁要谁来扣个1啊
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
29 29
扣1扣1啊
来来来来
29扣1啊
来喜欢的姐姐就扣29去扣个1啊
等我一分钟啊
再给你们过款
把后面的给你们过一下
这个又又得扫码
来
2929啊
谁要谁来扣个 strategies
来扣个 figuring
not
ㄤ
来只有好看
这个裙子很好看 00所以
让大家視وا
A4 看上面带一点亮晶晶的
黑色上面带一点亮晶晶
来这个牌子的
这个牌
走这里看
这个开始
来这个牌这个牌
能看清楚不
哎不对不对
他这个咋写的呀
怎么都是倒着的感觉
没有上面没有
里边没有水洗标
水洗标上面是啥也没写的
水洗标上面啥也没写
妈呀
咋搞的不精
来圆领圆领
短袖
袖子上面带珍珠扣的装饰扣
看看
他有点皱皱的
看这里有几颗装饰扣
来面料锯制的
锯制腰式松紧腰
腰式松紧腰
来我来量一下